it's a stretch really to call these even
protests it's very very difficult for
people to go out onto the streets and
protest any hint of somebody trying to
go out or looking like a protester and
are very often
violently dragged away uh by the police
the people in
the high visibility vests are
journalists by law they have to wear
those so they are on one side and the
police are dragging away people who
might look like they are a protester the
protests don't really get going in one
instance in one city a woman just
holding up a black blank piece of paper
uh was taken away by the police an
indication of how they are keen to crack
down on anything that looks like a
protest and one of the social media
channels you often see protest pictures
appearing is instagram it will be
blocked not specifically because of
spreading protest pictures but because
of a decision taken by instagram's
parent company meta who have relaxed
their hate speech rules on what users in
ukraine can say about
russia's war in ukraine russia's
invasion of ukraine and because of that
the russian authorities have said that
they want prosecutors want instagram and
uh meta the parent company facebook
declaring an extremist organization uh
and as part of that
instagram blocked 80 million instagram
users in russia like the rest of the
world it is ubiquitous it has its fair
share of influencers who make a living
on instagram
something like that being blocked will
be really noticed here there are other
channels of course though
you